GQ my essentials take one bro
what's going on everybody I am Noah
since now and I'm here with GQ today
we're doing my essentials okay so here I
got a I got a notebook this was a gift
from from my manager actually it has my
initials engraved in it and you see what
manager gave me this because he knows
that I love writing and journaling it's
kind of a way that I can get my thoughts
together because either they ricochet
around a lot and I find them I like to
like keep things in like I'm not really
good at expressing my thoughts to other
people so if I put them here then I can
kind of structure and organize them a
little bit if I'm if I'm like battling
with something you know if I'm like
really dealing with something that I'm
struggling with you know it's just
easier to write it down gotta have a
wallet in this modern-day we uh you know
you've all her re he's an Israeli author
he's like a social scientist if you will
he says that that money is like a
mythology almost it's a story it's a
narrative that's been told and it's a
very strong one because the world runs
on it right so economies form so if you
don't have money and you're in a bind
actually if you don't have money you
might be in a bind that's probably they
look like a cause for it as well so you
got to have a way to way to pay but then
again there are people that live with
absolutely no money which is an
interesting alternative lifestyle I keep
I keep my I keep a credit card I keep a
debit card
I keep an ID I keep a a key that gets me
to my managers crib just in case I want
to like surprise him late night imminent
spam and then I have a my insurance card
next item is a passport I mean look it's
a good form of ident identification and
you never know when you just want to
flee the country China yeah I did a
project in China it's called the diary
hasn't come out yet it's a Chinese
language film crazy it was fortunate
enough to get a 30 year visa to work in
China is it a 10 I've been telling
people it was 30 anyway my probably my
favorite place that I I've been is up
China I also went with my manager me and
my manager have a very close
relationship I love that dude yeah so 10
your visa to China it's pretty pretty
pretty dope I always keep books with me
this book is just what I'm reading
currently I'm reading I read a script
and I love the script a lot and the
character in the script reads Henry
Miller's Tropic of Cancer and then he
decides to move to Paris and be a writer
and so I just wanted to read the book I
was like damn like if this book could
inspire some of them it was not a writer
to move to Paris and be a writer that's
pretty dope even if it's you know from
the script this book was actually banned
in America for a very long time like you
weren't allowed to read it and now you
can't
and I'm not saying anyone should read
this book I'm definitely not being like
advocating for it but I'm thoroughly
enjoying it so but this is my fiction so
I got two books I get a nonfiction book
and then I got a fiction book and the
nonfiction is called the quants himself
by dan and so har it's a really cool
book that breaks down how science and
like discoveries and science can
influence the way that we perceive
reality and look at other people and
it's like science can influence the
epistemology meaning that you know back
in cartesian knowledge days like with
Sir Isaac Newton you know everything is
not connected so you have to separate
objects I thought that and it impacts
that one and I can also measure that
however hard I throw this at the angle I
throw it I know exactly where this book
will end up which created in science
when they learn that and they thought
they that was the way it goes
they believed that everything was
determined so then something called
determinism and when that came about
people were like there's no point to
anything
there's nothing I can do I'm not in
control of my life there's literally I
got you know it's determined for me and
that created this like kind of dark
period of modernism it was great because
we started making a lot of technological
advances but it was bad because we kind
of lost hope and being able to choose
our own paths but then with quantum
physics and new physics when that came
out it was like wait a second things
aren't really disconnected we just like
think they're disconnected and really
there's like that reality seems to be
more unitary and abstract the farther in
that we go it created this sense of
connection between all things so how
that could impact our culture and our
philosophy and epistemology is maybe I
shouldn't care about other people
instead of just bouncing off of them
maybe I should actually care and take
into account that I can control my own
life my own actions and instead of
hurting other people or hurting myself I
can learn from my mistakes and help
other people and it's cool it's it's a
great book about about about that not in
a nutshell in a very long stream of
conscious way of trying to describe what
I'm reading so yeah I gotta have my
fiction and my nonfiction this is a
Nikon f3 it's a film camera which means
like it open that it opens here and then
it burns an image onto film it's not
digital so you have to like change your
settings to adjust for light if you prep
the settings you probably won't make out
the picture it won't look the way you
want it to this is my second film camera
I don't know man I just I like being
able to document things
my grandfather had Alzheimer's and he
died from it so by the end of his life
you never remembered anything so it
would be really Nami not you know I hope
that doesn't happen to me you know it
does skip a generation so that's
definitely very real fear but more than
that I would like to be able to look
back on my life when I'm like 80 years
old the pictures that I took in that
other people took and I like the way
that film looks so they laid over it in
digital if you could figure it out I
suck so like all my photos don't turn
out but you know what
gotta have a phone you know I'm saying
you don't have a phone you're kind of
disconnected I like my phone because
first and foremost I can like correspond
with my friends and then second it's
good you know you can do if you have a
phone you pretty much have an office
your mobile office is your phone they're
so advanced nowadays that you can run a
business from your phone I love my phone
dearly and then obviously social media
and stuff I think we're all super
addicted to social media and I get to
interact with you with fans also like if
you're in a bind and something's going
on you're overseas or you know you're in
trouble your phone hmm can you call help
see this it's a phone charger you have a
phone but you don't have the charger you
don't got a phone you know I'm saying
you only have it for so long
so you got a charger and then you gotta
have a backpack you gotta be able to put
everything in your backpack it's the
mobile office you know everything goes
in it you throw it on your back and
there you go thank you guys so much for
the time thank you this has been amazing
thank you for letting me do my
essentials with y'all hope you enjoy